[Music]
right
i'm helen lederer uh i'm a
comedian from the 1980s not the eight
years ago i'm quite close
and i've set up the comedy women in
print prize
of which i'll be celebrating here at the
festival
and i've just done a rather stretching
gig about the purpose of play and work
lovely and so you've part of the debates
why do we
need ideas still why do we need debates
and talks and festivals like this
the atmosphere of people being here
knowing
that they have to talk is actually quite
unusual
so rather than people being buttoned up
and sort of
shy which can be an indulgence can be
you know you're in either
you could inherit shyness god forbid but
some people are inherited
there's no shyness here because people
are here to talk and listen and posit
opinions
it's quite unique i love it talking is
amazing
have you ever been a shy person or you
always been a talker
i'm i don't like silences i'm not great
at them
i can fill i can sort of i can sort of
go in there i can talk about minutia
just so there isn't a silence it may not
make sense and then if i carry on
talking i can get myself back
i think that comes from being a comedian
where you um it's like a sheepdog you
you just have to be controlling it
doesn't always work clearly but um
i'm not shy but i'm quite private so
this is the perfect
the perfect platform where you don't
have to actually be that personal
but you can actually exchange views and
learn it's brilliant
and so you launched the female comedy
prize
could you tell us more about this and
why you felt the need to launch it
so i launched the comedy women in print
prize i've been banging on about it for
four years i've exhausted myself
um and i've actually asked how the light
gets in festival to
do something before and this year
they're doing it i've got a whole hour
i'm bringing a comedian with me shazia
mercer and harper collins
is offering a publishing deal to the
winner of the unpublished
so the unpublished winner gets a novel
and five grand advance and the published
novel gets a bit of money but
it's so important to shine a light on
funny female fiction
there has been no price for it in the
past so i just have to quack on really
are there alternative or other prizes
out there
similar which aren't picking up women's
and female voices
the only other women's prize is one it's
called the women's prize for female
fiction
which is great and that's been going for
17 20 years i don't know but you know
that's established and
it's great uh and um
needed but nothing for wit nothing for
women witty authors
and i think this year more than ever
although i was there doing it in the 80s
it's suddenly yeah wit women's wits
driving the agenda and i go excuse me i
was
it's not new but and they've always been
funny women writers in history but
they haven't been visible so um there
was a gap in the market that's not
really why i did it i did it because i
was just cross and bitter
and that's quite a good motivator
because yeah i still cross a bitter and
we now have a prize for it and do you
think there's something
different about women's wit
to men's wit or you just think that it's
not as
uh like focal or like not giving enough
tension
yeah i know it's a good question because
um if
if you look at the statistics out of 24
humorous books
20 this year have been written by women
so the point is it's clearly happening
and yet there isn't a literary prize to
shine a light on it
and i'm not saying literary prizes come
up with the best winner they never do
it's all a process and the vibes in the
room and the scoring system
and the mood you know you never get the
best it
but it isn't about that it's about
creating a platform
of of merit uh and
uh people turn up to the awards and then
it's good i hope
what um so you talked about there's like
a financial prize
is that one of the what's the main
barriers that are stopping women's
voices from being heard in comedy or
recognized
well when you again when you look at the
body of work and the
fact that in the unpublished category we
had like 200 entries so
people had to have written a novel in
order to send it in
so there's definitely the work is there
and where there isn't a
parody is that the publishers have not
woken up to this
and they haven't seen it as an
opportunity
and then next year we want to expand it
into non-fiction because if you think
about
catelyn moran i'm sure you've read that
i mean my daughter's read that that's a
kind of coming-of-age group
you know how to be a girl how to be a
woman there are sort of game-changing
books out there
um and it's really important to shine a
light on those
so there's loads of work out there so
why shouldn't there be a prize you've
got your booker
uh you've got your costa you've got your
thissy you've got the vati
and now you've got something a bit
different and it's about
women being individuals so obviously in
the judging room
there were fisticuffs uh people have
very definite ideas about comedy
um people get very angry when people
differ
but it that's what it does so we're
trying to say it's okay to be an
individual
and a woman isn't quirky trying to ban
the word quirky
from a witty female voice they're not
quirky
they're just doing what virginia woolf
or muriel spark did
and do you think that separating women
out as its own sort of genre of
fiction could actually make it be seen
as
not equal or not on the same platform
well i mean i understand that and
i mean it is a bit bizarre when you're
going with all this kind of equality
you're actually
sort of doing a single gender so there's
a sort of paradox there but
i think because one didn't exist there
is a need
and when there isn't a need then i'd be
very happy to not do it
and get on my own blooming work which
has suffered hugely
so there's quite a personal sacrifice in
becoming a spokesperson yeah
because i honestly i've never
administrated anything i can't manage
people
i think everyone hates me i'm quite
paranoid and bitter and very
difficult with people so i am actually
making i am not the person who should be
doing this
but i did it i jumped in i had the idea
and i'm hoping that it can be
taken forward by somebody more sensible
have you felt like it's been quite a
sympathetic or supportive environment
like the literary world
and you're creating this prize i've i
noticed when i asked people
if they were interested everyone
said it was a great idea so you sort of
know it's like when you come up with a
a notion like i don't know paypal the
guy did paypal
obviously it worked because nobody
thought of it so i there was one person
a literary agent said
she didn't think there was enough female
fiction to warrant one female funny
fiction
i should say and i said well that's why
we need the prize so that was the only
dissent
so the thing is never listen to people
in authority just do it
is that something you've always thought
yeah i hate authority
figures i hate them i had a really
strict headmistress you had a dog
and i always got into trouble i don't
like people who say no
going back to this festival it's so
open-hearted and
open-minded it's my bliss because when
you meet someone you just know oh we're
gonna have a conversation
you don't have to go through all those
barriers of of judgment
and status and all that who are and
you've written
fiction yourself and you've also written
autobiography
well i haven't written the autobiography
that's because of the prize that's the
prize's fault
so um as soon as somebody else jumps in
and does this then i'm going to be
writing
a comedy memoir that may you may see in
the car boot because this does
this does tend to happen quite quickly
autobiography
car boot but hey i just have to do it at
this stage in my life i just gotta get
it down there
have you felt like comedy has been a way
for you to
deal with your own film that female
experience or experience of life
or do you think it can be a way that you
sort of don't deal with
reality or experience survive um well i
was just saying in the
play versus work workshop that you know
obviously being a fat asthmatic
child with a hairband that is a great
criteria to become
a comedian and the two fat people in my
class and the other one wasn't
funny so the whole point of
being who we are and using humor
to i don't know make
life uh purposeful
i suppose for me humor and being
historical if i possibly can
is my go-to place and it's a way of
engaging
with other people and having that
relationship humor really does do that
doesn't it i mean um
obviously it doesn't win over everyone
it can be very annoying
especially if i talk too much but i just
think being
playful in your work is
probably uh quite useful as a device
and have you found in you juiced on
stand-up comedy yourself
um have you found that a realm which is
open also to women
and women's experiences yeah well now
there's no need you know i mean
when i started there were three women
two of them had to have the same name
they're both called jenny so it wasn't
a stretch for the compat to introduce
them um
and the french and saunders had already
become
you know organization and were being
championed by the bbc
quite rightly so it was always one woman
on the bill
and very rare of course now i went to a
gig i had to judge this lgbt
um uh comedy show
uh the other night which is amazing you
think wow you know the material has
changed the boundaries have changed
and yet it's still can that person make
that room laugh
so um there are more opportunities there
are more agents
uh exploiting people making more money
there are more chat shows because it's
cheap tv
you know it's all nothing stays the same
but um
i'm i'm pleased i did it i didn't
particularly enjoy it but then i'm not
on this earth to enjoy things
what do you think you are on this earth
absolutely just to
try and crack on i think i think
doing the prize it can't stop now
is kind of like i've got to do something
i just felt i had to do something what
could i do other people are doing this
it's just that need to do something and
with all of us you go well what what's
affected you what do you feel angry
about what
what can you do i mean i don't have the
wherewithal i'm not like division a i
can't just
conjure up money to do a huge thing it's
a small thing it started small
so you have to do what you can do and
you've talked slightly a bit about
you said that you were the fat kid at
school and so you chose and you were
funny so you went
you chose comedy do you think that's
quite a
sort of current or like a similar theme
throughout
uh comics lives that they are in a sort
of a difficult position or
slightly out of the group so they use
comedy i think it's quite usual
but we all think we're the outsider it's
a bit of an affectation you probably
think you're the outsider and you're not
remotely fat
so of course now you can't actually use
fat in the same way because we've all
moved
with our language and our awareness and
feminism has really kind of evolved so
you know you now i wouldn't um talk
about it in the same way but i just
remember as a child
i was different from other people and
when you're different you have to make
it work
and are there sort of to use this
interview are there
um like female comedians or female
writers that you would recommend to
people
who you think should be championed
well obviously the world knows even
donald trump would know the word phoebe
wallabridge now i mean that
that is an amazing phenomenon what's
interesting is we get individual women
like
a few years ago it was miranda so it's
like the world
wants to do it but they don't they can
do it like with one
iconic figure which is great so what we
need is
to go and now can we all mesh in a kind
of ensemble way
as is the case with you know clusters
and clusters of male
performer writer commissioning editors
so but it's a start
but it would be quite nice not to have
individuals
uh put on pedestals so as brilliant as
they are
and i'm sure phoebe is such a team
player i didn't get a bafta the other
night and i saw her on stage
um and she is so lovely and so embracing
and creating work for other people and
so switched on so you know that's what
we need
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you